the storytellers show it's just a bunch
of funny people telling 100% true story
this is the first year I've ever talked
about this on stage tonight
this woman is traveling my face with a
12-inch black dildo and X calibers it
into my mouth brother fire my insides
are burning I go to the doctor and the
doctors like tell him we have to cut the
tip of his dick open
with an existential shattering of a
human soul 31 penis
is a party stopper one explosion of life
I laughed out loud peed one squirting
fart in her face knock on the door it's
the cops I'm like Oh No thank you in my
house black now large city arson more
than one
I'm sorry sir don't call my dad
percocets a lot of mushrooms cocaine we
lost we're high and were 10 yeah my
friend Santa's got all the puppies he's
got him captive band
I'm practically insane but I trust they
use caught up with a regular human woman
you'll be god damned if I just give it
to a homeless lady she could be sucking
my dick at deeds would still be gone
what are you doing later
first time Tara I think anyone I don't
balls-to-the-wall it was louder than any
jet engine it was
drink acid because I hate big
difference okay